the growing demand in the it industry
can make it confusing to pick one
programming language that is suitable
and helpful for an individual
so in this video we will walk you
through the top five programming
languages for the year 2021
this list can help you plan your career
in 2021 but number five we have
java so let's look into it java was
created by james gosling in the year
1991
it is the most demanding programming
language evident by its worldwide usage
java is known for providing the most
number of jobs in the it industry
java has a large application based in
the industry with the applications
ranging from scientific applications
financial and banking services to web
and mobile development
and desktop application development the
companies using java as their
programming language are ibm
hcl infosys among many others java
developers with a few years of
experience can earn nearly 117
000 pa and in india they can earn around
10 lakh rupees pa
next up we have the r programming
language r was conceived by robert
gentleman and ross ihaka in 1992.
r is a comprehensive and statistical
analysis language
and it encourages developers to
implement new ideas r works best on
linux
gnu and microsoft windows the
application of rs in the field of data
science
statistical computing and machine
learning although r is difficult to
learn it is considered as the future
programming language
the companies using rs their programming
language are capped gemini
cognizant accenture among many others
our developers with a few years of
experience can easily earn nearly 150
000
pa and in india they can earn around 9
lakh rupees pa
moving on to number three we have kotlin
kotlin is a general purpose programming
language
originally developed by jetbrains it is
interoperable with java and also
supports functional programming
languages
kotlin is used extensively for android
development web development
desktop application development and
server-side development
kotlin was built to be better than java
and people who use this language believe
it
most of the google applications are
based on kotlin the companies using
kotlin as their programming language
are coursera pinterest postmates among
many others
according to glassdoor kotlin developers
with a few years of experience can earn
nearly 140
000 pa and in india they can earn 8 lakh
rupees pa
next we have php php programming
language was initially created for the
purpose of maintaining a personal
website
but since then it has taken over 24 of
websites globally php language is
generally used to create static and
dynamic websites and some popular web
frameworks like laravel are built upon
php
php introduces dynamic changes to a
website and makes web applications more
interactive
the companies using php as their
programming language are facebook
yahoo mailchimp among many others
according to glassdoor php developers
can earn nearly 101 000
pa and in india they can earn around 7
lakh rupees pa
on average at first position we have
python programming language
python is the fastest growing and one of
the most popular programming languages
with reliable and well-built frameworks
it is open source and easy to learn
python is used in many areas in the
industry
django framework which is based on
python is popularly used in web
development furthermore python has
become the preferred programming
language for machine learning and
artificial intelligence
few of the big companies that use python
for development are instagram
spotify amazon and facebook python
developers can earn nearly 107
000 pa and in india they can earn around
8 lakh rupees pa
on that note why don't you check out the
simply learns postgraduate program in ai
and machine learning created in
partnership with purdue university
and in collaboration with ibm we'll
cover a number of topics and concepts
like statistics
python machine learning deep learning
networks
nlp reinforcement learning and much more
to help you grow in your career
and there you go those are the top 10
programming languages
in 2021 with that we've reached the end
of this video
do you agree with our top 10 list is
there any other programming language
that is worth learning in 2021
let us know in the comments thank you
for watching this video and stay tuned
for more from simply learn